제가 오늘은
성수동에
빌딩을 많이 매입한 기업 중에 하나인
크래프톤이 처음 매입한 빌딩 현장
앞에 와 있습니다
지금 뒤에 보이는 저 건물을
2020년에 176억 정도의
약 9,400만원 정도 되는데 최근에
이쪽 그 대로변에
분노 법인이 대지평당 한 2억 정도의
매입을 했어요 그래서 지금 한 3년
정도 지났는데
시세는
약 2백 정도 오른 것으로 예상이
됩니다 지금 여기도 중공업 지역이어서
건물을 좀 높게 올릴 수 있는 장점이
있는데 지금
따로 건축행위는 하고 있지 않은
것으로 좀 보여집니다
[음악]
그리고 제 개인적인 바램이 있다면
고가가 좀 없어졌으면 좋겠습니다
지하로 내려가든지이 고가 때문에 사실
여기 대로변이 좀
답답한
경향이 좀 있거든요
고가를
지하로 한다라는 얘기도 있고 되게
말이 좀 많은데 만약에이
고가를 지하 쪽으로 이렇게 내리게
된다라고 하면은이 오래 가치는 좀 더
높아질 것으로 좀 예상을 하고
있습니다 나머지 두 권은 한번 현장
가서 또 보도록 하겠습니다 아시죠
뒤에 보이는 건물이 여러분들 다들 잘
아실 겁니다 그래서 성수동 이마트
있는 자리인데 저 건물을
크래프톤에서
미래에셋이랑 같이 매입을 했습니다
그래서
총 매입가는 무려 1조
2,200억원에
매입을 했고 대지 평단가루만 봤을
때는 2억이 좀 안 됩니다 그래서 한
1억 9천 정도에
매입을 해서 지금 건물을 지으려고
지금 이제 그 펜스가 쳐져 있는데
요건물 같은 경우에는 설계를 저희
용산에 아모레퍼시픽을 설계하신 분이
계세요 그래서 그분이 지금이 건물도
설계를 맡아서 하고 계십니다 제가
조감도를 봤는데
정말 대한민국의 어떻게 이런
건물이라고 생각할 정도로
굉장히 좀 멋있게 건축이 되지 않을까
좀 예상이 됩니다 그래서
2027년을 이제 좀 목표로 건물을
짓는다라고 하는데 지금이 건물이 좀
어떻게 바뀔지 좀 되게 궁금합니다
그래서 지금 건물이 완성됐을 때
연면적인 약 한 6만 6천 평 정도
돼요 그래서 엄청납니다 그래서
아무래도 준공업 지역이다 보니까
이렇게 좀 건물 면적을 최대한 활용할
수 있었던 것 같습니다 이마트 부지가
어떻게 변할지 어 여러분들도 기대해
주시면 좋을 것 같고요 이쪽으로
가다보면 그 젠틀몬스터에서 또 건물을
매입해서 이제 신축을 하고 있어요
그래서 그것도 대지면적이
약 한 1,100평 정도 됩니다
그리고 지금 건물을 올리고 있는데
지금 그 건물 같은 경우에도 워낙 좀
저렴하게 매입했어요네 그 건물은
2017년도부터 매입해 가지고 그
옆에 부지도 18년도에 같이 매입해
가지고 지금 짓고 있습니다 두 개 다
합친 가격이 평당 한
5천만원 정도 밖에 안 될 거예요
근데 지금 이게 거의 2억 정도의
매입을 했으니까 그래서 그 지금
젠틀몬스터 부지도
땅값만 거의 뭐 2천억이
넘 이게 지금 말이 안 나오네요 제가
어 그래서 2천억 원이 넘습니다
그리고 지금 건물을 올라가면
훨씬 가격은 좀 높게
될 것으로 좀 예상이 되고요 그래서
이쪽 길도 좀 어떻게 변화하는지
여러분들이 좀 보시면 좋을 것
같습니다네 그럼 다음
크래프톤이 매입한 건물로 가보도록
하시죠
뒤에 보이는이 공장 부지를
크래프톤에서 또 샀습니다 지금이 앞에
있는 건물이랑 저 뒤에 있는 건물을
두 필지를 매입해 가지고 좀 건물을
신축할 것으로 좀 예상이 되는데 두
필지 다해서
약 한 640억 정도의 매입을
했어요네 그래서 돼지가 400평이 좀
안 되는데 이거는 1억 7천 저
뒤에는 1억 5천 정도에 매입을
했습니다 여기 시세 진짜 많이
올랐습니다네 그래서 여기도 지금 거의
뭐 한 2억 가까이 돼 가지고 가격이
굉장히 많이 올랐는데 여기도 어찌됐든
중공업 지역 용적률 거의 400%까지
받다 보니까 거의 건물을 뭐 한
10층 그 이상지지 않을까 좀 예상을
합니다
크래프톤이 매입한 건물을 좀 봤는데
여러분들은 좀 어떻게 생각을
하셨나요이 크래프트도 매입하고 그
다음에 무신사도 매입하고 그 우리가
알던 그 유망한 기업들이 다 이쪽에
매입을 했는데
앞으로 지금
성수동 남쪽
부분에 있는이 쪽 지역에
발전이 되게 궁금합니다 그래서
여러분들도 좀 이렇게 유명 기업들이
매입한 그런 건물들을 좀 유심히
보시면 좋을 것 같고 여러분들
투자하는데 있어서도
조금이나마 도움이 되셨으면 좋겠습니다
그래서 오늘 영상 여기까지 하고요
다음 시간에 뵙도록 하겠습니다
감사합니다